this is Startalk in the next few years
maybe 10 15 20 at most what do you see
as one of the most promising and
fascinating technological advances to
benefit humanity that you will be
watching with great interest I don't
write about of a genomics I'm really
fascinated to see what's going to happen
in an ethical way this is a big key with
technology swords and plowshares guys
it's morally neutral it's what we do
with it from the beginning of humanity
to the future of humanity
so with genome alteration we could do
some incredible things to stop horrible
diseases to create longevity to create a
happier humanity but we got to do it
right don't forget making a Minotaur ha
ha I think my favorite comic version of
genomic stuff are the Inhumans
right that they expose their children
their babies to the taragan mists and
then they wind up with very unusual and
interesting mutations and it's only the
royal family that gets it but anybody
else who wants it and then of over the
decades of course people have messed
with it a lot right and you mentioned
this a little bit earlier the idea of
pluses and minuses right and good actors
and bad actors using genomics is there a
particular fear you have for using
genomics in a bad way in the next 20
years not like far far future stuff but
but what could we really do bad aside
from say creating a super germ that
kills 99.9% of us in terms the rest of
us into zombies right all right aside
from the classic sci-fi runaway bug or
run away anything scenario I think it's
the I'm actually afraid of the
homogenize a tional manatee um I'm
afraid that people will think that
there's a certain advantage that's
preferable that everyone
we'll start to want that I'm really
interested in the therapeutic value
right now I want to see diseases go away
as much as possible but when we start
making the design or baby sing while on
one hand you could argue that it's a
moral necessity to create children who
will not have the problems of the past
you could also argue that you don't want
them to be created in a way that just
gets rid of our differences
now Emily I this might resonate with you
just a little bit because as we all know
you have a designer baby yeah it's just
great and what I want to ask you sort of
the same question you first let's let's
go with PJs idea first and this idea of
designer babies from a very personal
point of view as you're thinking about
the next month or years to come yeah and
then sort of your idea of what may be a
technological advance as some sort of
scientific advance in the next few years
that might really move us forward in a
way that's remarkable I think looking at
comic-con it's kind of hard to imagine
that we could ever homogenized
visit like this is this is my first
comic-con and oh we have to give her a
hand for that one all right
it is amazing I have never liked this
you know I tend to dress like this kind
of normally because I have my fashion
blog and stuff and I have never felt so
underdressed which is just amazing and
also like the yeah ha ha ha ha ha ha
knowledge EU has technology and and
children right now but then 20 years
from now what will your child they'll be
following that we are you know like I
can't work this here fix it for me and
even an ink about it'll be like now this
is easy look this is this is part of
life you know I mean okay this is a
little bit personal but also like I
would not be pregnant if I were born 30
years ago because I had IVF okay and so
that's like something that did not exist
was not readily accessible in my parents
generation
and it's something like if you you know
ask like a handful of woman if you're
more likely to do it on the Upper East
Side you know if you ask the pregnant
woman like one out of two words are
pregnant using IVF and so it's like it's
actually a fairly commonplace thing
which is fantastic
and it's you know it's not quite
designer babies I think is very very
ethical but it's it's fantastic to think
about you know living in this time when
so many things that just weren't
possible a little while ago are now
entirely possible
I remember what's going to happen in the
future I remember as a child the first
in Restore fertilized children what the
huge like baby baby yeah it's actually
like in life it was a tremendous moral
issue people were protesting some of
these doctors saying you know you are
creating Frankenstein's and monsters and
so forth and a decade later decades
later EJ it's always the same argument
we've had the same argument about the
natural order of things that you could
actually just take out the technology
and we've had the same arguments in some
Middle Ages if you like this please
remember everything that we do can be
found commercial-free plus exclusive
original content all on Startalk all
access com